The Rockstar with a PhD... and 8 other Facinating
Facts
1.
A mentally ill man, William Chester Minor,
while a patient at the Broadmoor Asylum for
the Criminally Insane in Britain, became the
largest contributor to the first edition of
the Oxford English Dictionary.
He later cut off his penis and was sent back
to the United States…
(QF 647)
2.
During mating, the force of the honeybee male’s
ejaculation is so strong, the resulting process,
including the rupture of the drone’s penis,
is sometimes audible making a “pop” noise.
The price of the drone’s 1 to 5 second sexual
escapade is his life, as his reproductive
bits are ripped from his body after climax…
what a buzz kill.
(QF 610)
3.
It wouldn’t be until 15 years after basketball
was invented before someone got the bright
idea of putting a hole in the bottom of the
basket to allow the ball to pass through so
it wouldn’t have to be manually retrieved
every time someone made a shot.
(QF 576)
4.
Stanfordrejects.com redirects to Berkeley.edu…
(QF 638)
5.
Since February of 2012, Rialto, California
has required all police officers to wear a
camera to monitor all interactions with the
public.
After this practice was instituted, the number
of complaints to the department dropped by
88%.
Further, the number of instances of the police
using “force” on people dropped 60%.
As the chief of police there said, “When
you put a camera on a police officer, they
tend to behave a little better, follow the
rules a little better…”
One imagines that knowing that footage is
available also cuts down on made up complaints.
(QF 639)
6.
In the original The Little Mermaid story,
the Little Mermaid endures excruciating pain
“like walking on sharp swords” as a price
for getting legs.
Also, the Prince falls in love with someone
else and marries them instead.
The Little Mermaid is given the chance to
become a mermaid again, if she kills the prince
and drips is blood on her feet, but she chooses
not to and throws her body into the sea where
it disintegrates and she turns into a “daughter
of the air” spirit.
(QF 633)
7.
In 1955, the largest solid gold statue in
existence (Phra Phuttha Maha Suwan Patimakon)
was accidentally discovered when a 13th or
14th century statue of Buddha that was covered
in plaster was being moved.
Being significantly heavier than anticipated,
the ropes used to move the statue snapped
and the statue fell, breaking off some of
the plaster.
Underneath, they found the statue of solid
gold estimated to be worth about a quarter
of a billion dollars just from the raw value
of the gold today.
(QF 625)
8.
The hit Carpenters song “We’ve Only Just
Begun”, ranked as the 405th best song of
all time by Rolling Stone magazine, was originally
written for a wedding themed Crocker National
Bank commercial.
(QF 586)
9.
The lead guitarist in one of the greatest
rock bands of all time, Queen, has a PhD in
Physics.
He began the program before he joined up with
Queen, but then dropped out, finally going
back and completing his PhD in 2007.
(QF 577)